for 20 years yokozuna hakuho has set
records that will stand in japan's
traditional sport for decades but
advancing age and injuries have forced
the 36 year old to step out of the ring
for the final time
hakuho's last event was in july when he
took home a record 45th championship
13 more than any other
[Applause]
all the more impressive considering he
was an outsider when he started
i was lucky to have sumo instinct when i
started
my father was a grand champ at mongolian
sumo and he was a silver medalist at the
mexico olympics in wrestling
i grew up watching him so i think i have
a little of his dna in me
but when i first joined i was very
skinny and small
and i had a hard time eating
but as i got bigger and bigger and
higher and higher up the ladder
i still had a problem winning
strength-wise
and i couldn't speak japanese then
so there were a lot of hurdles that i
had to clear
like these young sumo wrestlers hakuho
was born in mongolia and had to rise
through the ranks
he became just the second mongolian-born
grand champion with many of the older
japanese generation unhappy about what
they saw as foreigners taking over the
sport
but despite dominating in the ring
hakuho believes it's important to be
humble as he explained to al jazeera in
an interview back in 2008
if i may borrow one all grand champion's
words
being a grand champion is a destiny so
you just have to be what you are there
are only two grand champs
but they are above all other restless so
you have to be more than just strong
you have to have charisma and manners
and be a role model for the other
wrestlers
and that could be what he'll do next
having been given japanese citizenship
in 2019 hakuho is reportedly considering
opening a stable in japan to train young
wrestlers to show gratitude to his
beloved sport
dorsa jabari al jazeera